et méridienne un festival original et
très attendu des tourangeaux et des
curieux 30 minutes de concert la pause
de midi est une invitation au voyage
dans le temps avec de la musique du
moyen-âge ou baroque mais aussi dans le
monde
j'adore les musiques du monde je fais le
festival que j'ai envie d'entendre
dedans que je me fais plaisir et je suis
heureux que sa rencontre aussi le
plaisir de beaucoup de gens donc on va
en afghanistan on va en inde
on va aller en irlande on voyage aussi
dans les musiques traditionnelles
françaises parce que dans le monde il ya
la france il ya beaucoup de voyages très
intéressant à faire aussi en tweets
guerbert qui est aussi la tête de
diabolus in musica un ensemble de
musique ancienne et toujours à la
recherche de musiciens talentueux comme
ce quatuor de saxophone tuba français
opus 333
[Musique]
de jeunes musiciens qui apprécient le
concept du festival avec la rencontre du
public autour de dégustations de
produits locaux
on est une petite parenthèse dans la
journée dès les gens c'est très agréable
parce qu'on sent qu'il ya une écoute qui
est différente
une réception de la musique est
différente c'est vraiment un petit
moment à part essayer du coup il ya une
écoute d'une très grande qualité donc
c'est vraiment extrêmement agréable
[Musique]
moi je trouve que c'est très bien parce
que c'est vraiment mettre la musique et
la musique classique à la portée de tout
le monde c'est très bien situé parce que
c'est au début des vacances donc les
gens sont pas tous encore partie entre
midi et deux c'est encore plus génial
parce qu'avec la dégustation donc il ya
un an semble un petit peu qui rien à mix
entre des bonnes choses qu'on mange et
puis des bonnes choses qu'on entend moi
je trouve que c'est une vraie réussite
au fil des ans le festival a évolué en
proposant des cafés sieste avec lectures
musicales et des concerts en soirée pour
fêter ses 10 ans une grande fête
irlandaise clôturera les méridienne 14
juillet sur la place châteauneuf à tour